so the answer to the question is it
technically possible absolutely with
today's technology we can we can launch
a human venture to march now it'll be
very very expensive and we will have to
you know justify that that huge
expenditure likely by enlisting the
collaboration of the spacefaring nations
of the globe to do it jointly actually
nASA has created what they call design
reference missions that involve pre
positioning fuel pre positioning a
habitat pre positioning a communication
system and a return device in in Martian
orbit
Claire I think that is an absolutely
wonderful idea there is places on the
moon where we have water in the form of
ice embedded inside the lunar regolith
of course water is an essential building
block to sustaining human life and being
able to extract that water out of the
lunar regolith and use it to drink to to
disassociate into oxygen and hydrogen
oxygen to breathe and hydrogen to use
for fuel I cannot think of a next
natural step that mankind can take off
the planet other than to set up a
permanent colony on I feel as though we
can't afford not to do it as you had
mentioned we're not doing a wonderful
job of taking care of our planet here on
earth I wonder if perhaps you know we
always expect the best but you know
sometimes bad things happen and is it
good to perhaps set out and maybe make a
place that somebody can go in the event
something bad happens on earth so and
that's not the only reason to go but
that is a reason to consider sort of a
preservation of the species theory and I
personally believe it's a great
insurance policy for the human race
my name is Christopher Ferguson I'm a
former NASA astronaut and I've blown on
three different shuttle flights I now
work for The Boeing Company is the
deputy program manager for operations
for the cst-100 Starliner Commercial
Crew program